guys like is like a pill that's coated
with sugar it's a bitter pill but you
know you caught it with with a nice film
of sweetness so that people pop it into
their mouths and by the time they know
it they've already swallowed that very
bitter pill Nigerian writer on earth and
John specializes in thinking outside the
box and giving his readers food for
thought more than 80,000 readers
regularly read his online articles in
which he holds a mirror up to society
whether corrupt politicians slow-moving
bureaucracy all the human weaknesses of
the average nigerian he misses nothing
and with his material he creates texts
full of refined irony and subtle wit
it's very easy to write a long angry
article but sometimes people it may be
more effective if people are able to
look at a mirror and see themselves and
have a good laugh at the silliness that
goes on and
politics the 34 year old was raised a
Christian and Nigeria's majority Muslim
north he made the increasing religious
and political radicalization of his
homeland the subject of his latest book
born on a Tuesday it tells the story of
a Muslim street kid he gets caught in
between Islamist and political power
interests it's a current topic also in
Europe sometimes we need to dig a bit
deeper because of the way international
news is is easy to just give two minute
news items about a big conflict that's
happening in Nigeria without discussing
the intricate details of of the conflict
the reasons for the concrete only human
beings that exists in the skull field
other than John shows that things are
never really that straightforward that
the world people and conflicts are
complex and multi-layered even if we
want to see things in black and white
and find simple solutions